rage versus results and the great
Democrat freaked out that's the focus of
tonight's angle being a liberal means
never having to say you're sorry
an overstatement well maybe but given
some of the more recent politically
inspired acts of vandalism and violence
and of defamation and libel it's closer
to the truth than not
ten years ago even five years ago it
would have been unthinkable that major
political and media figures would bend
over backwards to excuse criminal
behavior because they agreed with the
perpetrators political motivation yet in
this age of rage this happens all too
frequently didn't Jessi conflate the two
didn't he in fact attempt to paint the
Magus supporters as these racist and
homophobic people I think is true that
yeah I want but in the show I have to
respectfully disagree I think mango
supporters have painted themselves as
that okay well the jussie Smollett case
is all at once depressing and
enlightening what's depressing because
so many seem positively giddy they were
thrilled that a hate crime like that
would have happened finally they could
draw a direct line from the support for
Trump to support for almost a lynching
you had a noose you had a racial and
anti-gay slur it was a politically
perfect storyline that pushed all the
right anti Trump buttons a Hollywood
star who's black and gay and now the
victim of a heinous crime yeah I did the
racial slurs and maybe even some of the
homophobic slurs being used toward him
you can see how serious this crime is
right now absolutely despicable
in 2019 so now even when it seems like
the entire thing was a sixer aid the
race hustlers remain undaunted hey
interesting when you when you use hatred
and bigotry and lying for your own self
is handing your young black kid a black
kid you get indicted if you do it when
your old white guy you become president
and I think there are enough monsters
out there for real that we don't them
making yet and I think that you know
what white supremacist has never had a
historical high no focus on that last
line for just a moment white supremacy
in 2019 it's worse than it was let's say
in 1963 in Birmingham Alabama
when water cannons and dogs were
released on civil rights marchers when
children were blown up in churches Trump
hating comedians undeterred by actual
facts are suddenly aggressively unfunny
comedian Billy Eichner saying if it
turns out the attack was staged that is
disgusting but don't give me any BS
about Magga supporters being the victim
here a bunch of white supremacists
falsely accused of inspiring a crime are
still a bunch of white supremacist they
poison the soul of our country and of
the world and the crimes against
humanity will be felt long after we've
forgotten about jussie Smollett crimes
against humanity okay Billy like what
policies that grow the economy and spur
wage and job growth growth across the
board including for african-americans
that crime against you and humanity or
the crime against humanity of creating
what Opportunity Zones and some of our
most debilitated communities or is it
the crime of criminal justice reform
that's a crime against humanity you see
what I'm saying it's patently ridiculous
but this is all very enlightening is it
not because here's what's really
happening Trump's policies are actually
working we see it all around us the
Muller report it looks like it's going
to be a dud and liberal heroes are self
combusting before our very eyes so
the Democrat Protectorate are in total
freakout mode let's look back there
Kavanagh accuser blase Ford flamed out
their indigenous 2020 hopeful Elizabeth
Warren was knocked off her high horse
Virginia's Democrat leaders are tangled
up in blackface and me two scandals and
now with small it their dream of the
perfect Trump inspired hate crime has
also fizzled so now we're back to Donald
Trump Bing Hitler Pol Pot and Stalin all
rolled into one that's the best they
have and while they mild the requisite
if jessie did it and this is wrong well
they quickly then revert to their title
our tired old narrative that today
minorities should live in fear comedian
hari kondabolu tweeting what Jesse
Smollett is accused of is despicable
however don't forget that we believed he
was the victim of such horrendous hate
crime because it's the type of thing
that happens way too often especially in
the Trump era he may have taken
advantage of a very realistic fear and
the queen of racial fear-mongering mad
Maxine Waters she freely admits she
believed Jesse's ridiculous story
because his views checked all the
liberal boxes he's a friend he was at my
office we marched in the pride Raima get
together he introduced me at the black
girls rock and so III believed him when
I heard about it well if congressman
Waters wanted to learn something she
might try to engage with black Americans
who see this all very differently they
aren't looking to blame Trump or
conservatives for all of their woes past
or present what they're looking for are
real solutions and real hope every
citizen alive today and generations yet
unborn are forever in debt of the brave
souls who stared down injustice and
championed the eternal cause of civil
rights
and by the way as you've been hearing me
say african-american unemployment is at
an all-time low historic well the scene
last night at the White House as part of
what inspires the ongoing Democrat
freakout the real possibility that
President Trump at the Black History
Month celebration it was oversubscribed
have more than 300 people people
couldn't even get in that maybe just
maybe Donald Trump could peel off 5%
maybe even 10% more of the black vote in
2020
that's unnerving to the left but there's
a new movement emerging I really don't
even understand why so many people hate
black people what people that look like
me and him hate this president because
this man has done more than any other
president has done for people that look
like me and him
I always said don't get caught up in the
emotions what about the s whole
country's comment and what about well
you know it's always that solution don't
pay bills that don't do anything except
keep this junk going here well the
Democrats race-baiting in the
fear-mongering it's only gonna go so far
but if they keep it up emotionally worn
out african-american voters may do what
Democrats fear most tune them out and
focus on Trump's record of
accomplishment in their communities and
that's the angle